c'est le temps des vacances c'est le
temps du farniente mais c'est aussi le
temps vous savez le moment opportun pour
les visiter les monuments de toutes
sortes qui marque la carte touristique
parmi les lieux qui sont très fréquentés
se trouve le château des ducs de
bretagne se trouve à nantes songez que
ce site a été visité en effet par trente
mille personnes rien que pour le mois de
juillet à l'origine de cette curiosité
bien évidemment le mauvais temps mais le
mauvais temps du début de la saison mais
aussi le goût des français de plus en
plus prononcée pour les vieilles pierres
entre 30 et 35 milles visiteurs par mois
c'est la moyenne de fréquentation que
connaît le château des ducs à nantes
pendant l'été près de la moitié sont des
étrangers venus de l'europe du nord et
des îles britanniques
et parmi ces visiteurs également de
vieux nantes est tout heureux de faire
profiter de leurs connaissances tous ces
touristes étrangers
il revient souvent me promener ici pour
mon plaisir mais je suis jeune et je ne
sais pas partie de l'administration du
château
c'est pour mon plaisir je suis animateur
alors pourquoi vous venez ici bas qu'on
prend le relais et j'aime beaucoup les
vieux château les vieilles pierres et
tout ça ça m'intéresse pas alors sous le
ce grand escalier là il ya beaucoup de
nantais qui ne savent pas ce qui s'est
passé il ya une cellule qui a contenu un
des plus célèbres personnages de
l'époque de louis xiv
c'est à dire nicolas fouquet
surintendant des finances de louis xiv
un château chargé d'histoire qui abrite
dans son sein de musée permanent le
musée d'art populaire régionale et le
musée des salorges le musée de la marine
ainsi qu'une exposition temporaire
consacrée aux géants de la route peut
compter 1000 personnes par jour environ
en moyenne le jour le plus fort c'est ce
dimanche tout en comptant environ 15 116
110 700 personnes de la famille plus de
trente mille personnes par une morale
mois est-ce que ses supérieurs à l'an
dernier
c'est vrai la même chose peut-être que
c'est il ya quelques miu 2000 ans en
plus pour à convoi ça de plus près par
rapport à 1981 dans la mesure où
l'exposition les gens de la route a
connu un très gros départ vu que le 4 et
5 juillet qui était
des journées inaugurales notamment le 4
juillet nous avons eu quatre mille trois
cents personnes pour un week-end ce
qu'elle un chiffre record
cette exposition les géants de la route
consacré à l'histoire du vélo et du tour
de france sera ouverte jusqu'au 31
octobre
elle a connu une forte fréquentation
bien sûr à l'époque du tour de france
mais elle suscite toujours autant
d'intérêt auprès des visiteurs visiteurs
qui sont plus nombreux au château que
dans les autres musées de la région
quant au temps maussade en juillet il
n'a guère eu une influence sur le nombre
d'entrées au château la moyenne
journalière de 1000 visiteurs
enregistrés le mois dernier étaient de
la même pendant les mois d'été de
l'année 1980 entre 30 et 35 milles
visiteurs par mois c'est la moyenne de
fréquentation que connaît le château des
ducs à nantes pendant l'été près de la
moitié sont des étrangers venus de
l'europe du nord et des îles
britanniques
et parmi ces visiteurs également de
vieux nantes est tout heureux de faire
profiter de leurs connaissances tout
sept touristes étrangers
il revient souvent me promener ici pour
mon plaisir mais je suis jeune et je ne
sais pas partie de l'administration du
château
c'est pour mon plaisir je suis amateur
alors pourquoi vous venez pour prendre
l'air et j'aime beaucoup les lieux
château les vieilles pierres et tout ça
ça m'intéresse pas alors sous le ce
grand escalier là il ya beaucoup de
nantais qui ne savent pas ce qui s'est
passé il ya une cellule qui est contenue
un des plus célèbres personnages de
l'époque de louis xiv
c'est à dire nicolas fouquet
surintendant des finances de louis xiv
un château chargé d'histoire qui abrite
dans son enceinte de musée permanent le
musée d'art populaire régionale et le
musée des salorges le musée de la marine
ainsi qu'une exposition temporaire
consacrée aux géants de la route peut
compter 1000 personnes par jour environ
en moyenne et le jour le plus fort c'est
son dimanche on compte environ 15 116
110 700 personnes la famille plus de
trente mille personnes par une morale
mois est-ce que ses supérieurs à l'an
dernier
c'est vrai la même chose peut-être que
c'est il ya quelques 1000 ou 2000 ans en
plus pour à convoi sera de plus près par
rapport à 1981 dans la mesure où
l'exposition les gens de la route a
connu un très gros départ vu que le 4 et
5 juillet qui était
des journées inaugurales notamment le 4
juillet nous avons eu quatre nus 300
personnes pour un week-end ce qui est un
chiffre record
cette exposition les géants de la route
consacré à l'histoire du vélo et du tour
de france sera ouverte jusqu'au 31
octobre elle a connu une forte
fréquentation bien sûr à l'époque du
tour de france mais elle suscite
toujours autant d'intérêt auprès des
visiteurs visiteurs qui sont plus
nombreux au château que dans les autres
musées de la région
quant au temps maussade en juillet il
n'a guère eu une influence sur le nombre
d'entrées au château la moyenne
journalière de 1000 visiteurs
enregistrés le mois dernier et elle a
même pendant les mois d'été de l'année